the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so first of all thank you for being here
we've talked about immigration in the
past and the very nature equities I
think it also applies and one of the
themes that we studied at leat with
Professor chairman was what's the actual
reason that people do not want
immigrants in the country versus the
reasons that they state so for example
one of the reasons that people with
state would be that immigrants are
earning in the economy one of the
reasons why people people stay oh sorry
one of the reasons that people's state
that they don't want the immigrants from
the country Oh state yeah it's because
they said that immigrants who were in
the economy but then professor Sherman
pointed out the fact that Mayor
Bloomberg of New York for the former
Mayor Bloomberg of New York said that
New York cannot run without immigrants
so what do you think are the actual
reasons that people do not want
immigrants in the country well first of
all it's not a new phenomenon and it's
not the United States so for example in
Europe a majority of the population of
Europe majority thinks that their
addition that Europe should not permit
any Muslim immigrants okay Europe has a
certain history like it's called
crematoria for example that's part of
the background and that's part of the
immigration background here too I can
talk about if a very personal point of
view my father my mother my father
happened to be able to come to the
United States before the fleeing from
Czarist Russia horrible conditions for
especially for Jews he made it before
the Immigration Act of 1924 1924
Immigration Act for the first time
barred Europeans prior to that there
were racist immigration acts like kept
out Orientals but Europeans were
admitted and there was a very simple
reason for that we were exterminating
the indigenous population so it was a
lot of open space that's what you see
glory
and stories about covered wagons going
to the West the pioneers of course they
were displacing some people who happen
to live there but it's another story
anyway there was an open the continent
was open after you've exterminated the
population and you want the right kind
of people to come in and if you go back
the question of the right kind of people
was quite delicate so for example
Benjamin Franklin who was the leading
figure of the Enlightenment in the
United States he thought we should have
discriminatory immigration rules to keep
out the wrong kind of people of people
who were too dark and the people who
were too dark were Swedes and Germans ok
that's Benjamin Franklin so we got to
watch out keep out Germans and Swedes
they're too swarthy but that was finally
relaxed anyway they needed Europeans to
come in by the beginning of the 20th
century that they didn't need immigrants
any longer to fill the country and the
constant racism emerged so the 1924 act
was basic I mean in reality it was based
against Jews and Italians what they said
is east and southern Europeans that I'm
intrusion Italians well ok what happened
to the Jews who weren't unable to come
until the 1960s and they're up in
concentration camps in crematoria so
it's a serious issue that's most my
family incidentally but the ones who
didn't make it you know but so the story
goes way back it's not something new and
it's not just the United States Western
society generally is infected by a very
deep racism and it's even more extreme
in many ways in Europe than
the united states in fact in europe it's
even more frightening than the united
states so take this morning's newspaper
if you happen to look at it
the government of Austria has there was
a coalition government that it wasn't
able to have an agreement so they have
to have an election and the concern is
that the most popular figure in Austria
might win the election he happens to be
in do not see that's Austria there's a
little bit of history in Austria okay
well that's that's scary and it's
happening all over the here it's here it
has a special character because of the
white supremacy
the white supremacy is very deeply
rooted in the United States there are
comparative studies of white supremacy
the major ones by Georg Fredrickson so
super good sociologists who did a
comparative study of white supremacy in
many countries it's more extreme in the
United States than any country that he
studied including South Africa under
apartheid and you see it all over the
place I mean when the Nazis in the early
thirties were trying to find models for
the Nuremberg Laws the racist laws they
looked around the world the only country
where they could find good models was
the United States and they took US
models of the US had miscegenation rules
rules against interracial marriage which
lasted in fact until they were finally
struck down in the 1960s the Nazis
didn't entirely take the u.s. laws
because they regarded the u.s. laws too
harsh so the u.s. laws were based on the
concept of one drop of blood none of
this means anything you know from a
biological point of view it's all
totally meaningless but you know
these are constructs socially
constructed categories and one drop of
blood meant of you by whatever category
was concocted you had one drop of Negro
blood your black and then you can't
marry a white those were laws that were
not struck down I think until 1967 I
mean and it you see it all over the
place right now I mean it's right in
front of us all over the in fact if you
if you look at African history and the
United States pretty remarkable in fact
that something that really should be
studied
I'm the two topics that should be
studied are what happened to the native
population and what happened to the
black population anything else is
secondary for the United States without
going through the details I presume you
know them but in the first slaves were
brought and here Massachusetts said four
hundred years ago that's four hundred
years you look over those four hundred
years there have been literally a few
decades maybe thirty years
scattered in which African Americans had
a kind of a small opportunity to enter
the general society that's quite a
record and of course it has a residue
the residue shows and things like
immortality wealth the wealth of
african-american families is virtually
zero what there was was pretty much
destroyed by the crash and it shows up
the you know the wire their murders and
ghettos and Chicago and Baltimore and
south and the genes know
everywhere you look you see and shows up
I wasn't going back to your question it
shows up in the racist immigration laws
which are bad enough now but the ones
that were enacted in 1924 and maintained
right through the Holocaust oh those
were pretty serious in fact you probably
know the stories but ships were turned
away bringing refugees who thought they
could make it I mean there's some
strange stories if you look at it
they're kind of suppressed but one quite
interesting stories worth looking at if
you're interested is nesting with Japan
the Japanese fascists were kind of only
had a limited understanding of the
Western world Japan had been pretty
isolated
so the fascist leaders the general Japan
in the 1930s were pretty much influenced
by Germany and they knew that they read
German propaganda Nazi propaganda about
how Jews are running the world and they
were very eager to get the Americans off
their back you know they didn't want to
conflict with the United States so they
concluded that the way to get the
Americans off their back is by doing
something nice for the Jews and this in
fact fit with Japanese history because
in the early part of the 20th century
there was a Russell Japanese war and
Jewish wealthy Jews who were very anti
Russian because Russia was very
anti-semitic were funding and supporting
the Japanese Jacob Schiff and others and
that was from Japan considered that that
was part of the reason why they were
going to win the war so they had their
own connections with
international Jewish conspiracy that
roams the world that they were picking
up from Nazi propaganda so they
concluded that the way to mollify the
United States was to bring Jews from
Eastern Europe to Japan
and what there was a period of the Nazi
Russian pact you know where people could
move and in fact there was a
considerable number of Polish Jews very
Orthodox Polish Jews the kind you see
with black hats and white shirts you
know yes and all this you see they were
brought from Poland to Japan which was a
feudal society the culture of contact
was incredible visits of all sorts of
interesting stories about it but the
point here is that the Japanese assumed
that if they brought Polish Jews to
Japan the american jewish community
would welcome them here they didn't want
them to stay in Japan of course they
thought they'd go on to the United
States they stayed in Japan not nobody
wanted them here including the Jewish
yeah there's plenty of stories like that
as soon as you start to lift the veil
very slightly
I find it everywhere
you